as I watched the series there Jeff I was
struck that in most episodes you seem to
get a lot of free stuff well no you may
have gotten a misimpression that's not
what I'm in it for uh and this show I
got some nice stuff but only a couple of
things but they were very nice in that
episode where I visited Detroit bikes on
our episode about bicycles they made me
a bicycle I didn't have an adult bicycle
as I tell them I have in my backyard and
I ride with my two sons I love that and
then oh I forgot to get I'm gonna run
away because I forgot I was going to
show you something that I got from this
where I visited I'm gonna get it I'll be
right at it I'll be right back
don't okay fine I'll tell you well that
can design shelves behind this but I'll
be right I'll be right back okay yeah
yeah I'm so sorry I had we had cook this
up but I forgot I put it in my closet I
there was an episode on jewelry we went
to Johnny Dangs place who does a lot of
things for sports stars and hip-hop
artist and he made me a grill you know
what a grill is a grill for you is it
for your mouth
yeah it's teeth I'll put it off shame
both sets oh dang
[Laughter]
[Music]